advice from ebay founder pierre omidyar  i seen in zucca 101 find your passion I  was just pursuing what I enjoy doing I  mean I was pursuing my passion it's not  really work if you're having fun that  was the case with me you should pursue  your passion if you're passionate about  something and you work hard than I think  you'll be successful I always wanted to  be involved with computers like most  software people is very much passion  more than anything else the ability to  create software that could have a  benefit or an impact on people that used  it was what was driving me I was just  very excited about learning everything I  could you have to really believe in what  you're doing be passionate enough about  it so that you'll put in the hours and  hard work that it takes to actually  succeed there and then you'll be  successful to learn more check out zucca  101 find your passion in the link below